[Music]
it's official
congratulations mr president joe biden
is the president of the united states
and you might want to grab a box of
tissues
because some of hollywood's biggest
stars were on hand
to bring all the freaking feels with
their musical performances
the will of the people has been heard
and the will of the people
has been heeded on wednesday biden was
sworn in as the 46th president of the
u.s
and kamala harris as vice president by
kamala davey harrison
lady gaga brought down the house rocking
a custom shop pirelli hot couture look
as she
sang the national anthem
[Music]
jennifer lopez fought back tears as she
made her way to the mic to saying this
land is your land
and america the beautiful below
this land was made for you and
me the triple threat who is a passionate
voice for the latinx community
wore chanel head to toe and recited
two lines of the pledge of allegiance in
spanish
she also threw in a little nod to her
own song with this
let's get loud moments
i'm here for that
[Music]
[Applause]
after biden and harris took the oath of
office garth brooks sang an acoustic
rendition of amazing grace
how sweet the
sound and after all of that hollywood
was quick to celebrate biden and harris
on social media
oh we stood out didn't did we not i was
like
angela bassett shared a pic of the
capital on instagram
writing in part quote hey everybody
today we're all good
god bless you real good joe biden and
kamala harris
our country in your hands is a great
good thing
amen amen and amen how does your heart
feel are you excited
filled every day like i just the joy
eva longoria shared a snap with the new
prez writing that today we make history
while former president barack obama
congratulated his friend
posting this pic with the former veep
and tweeting this
is your time and his wife former flotus
michelle obama
admitted she's feeling relief and is
genuinely hopeful for what's to come
it's about never stopping bibi rexa
tweeted that it is never too late to
chase your dreams
and maria shriver echoed that writing
may we all take inspiration from their
story
good people do finish first
you